[音楽]
ni
やってみましょうか遺書
じゃあことを願いします
今日
梅の有名人の二弾浮き打って拍手をしています
さあ
いっ照明さんちょっと会場も見えます
hey
[音楽]
ale あっ詰まったミーハーほど言葉
俺が溢れる has しかーし
anus 式余興も ok あれば処方
den o 4矢橋町虚妄
こんな感じで頃行ったいるまさかもエッジで face r
ano デー
市民のリスクを背負って俺根本大臣なんやー
タブリエバッカーやっぱりちょっとないかでもまぁファンってやってみましょう
いやいや
ウォンや ran 500円そして俺は今皆を確認
そして母ファックシーンのブーバーレンジャーしてそのプロパティとなられぬああ
ああっませ
nan nan じぇい
[音楽]
[拍手]
ガーどうもありがとうございます
西へ
re
熱によってまいりました xuse
僕が法ということで
僕の仕上がりですね5000円になるのか
水公平になるのかかかっておりますんで一生懸命やらせていただきました
越冬
んでしょ
この皆さんお持ちのこのパンフレットがあると思うんですけど
a
はい最後も2ページ目ですね
に広告が映ったわけですよ
ねえねえなんかパイナップルみたいなあのがシャツを着て
その謎のハンチング帽かぶってですねやっておりました
これは一ヶ月前ですね3ヶ月じゃないか
えっとてとのあの
オーディションの時ですね
8この時まだ僕別であの
アイティフォー蒸すという名前でも活動したんですけど
まあ今はですねちょっとキャラを変えてラッパーとして活動します
[音楽]
ブーブー言ってる2倍ぐらい ikea にょろさて私の前
パン窯雑誌って名前を聞いたことがある方いらっしゃいますか
ee 版の舌でございます
ファンがいっぱいいるとハイトーン会場のでき大丈夫です
はい
とさっきですね20分前に話すことを変えたんでちょっと共鳴もう見ながらしたいん
ですけども
あのつまりですね
花深いはもうみんな知ってるわけですけど名前は知られていないという
返答このことを僕はその6命の有名じっていうふうに定義をしています
そしてですねえっと今日のまあその話の軸の中で大事なもう一つのポイントがあるん
ですけど
坂岡さんていうのはなんか今日の桜とには
パイナップルのアロハを着てくるはずだと
多分まあ関係者と神ボスだと思うね
ところはこんな罰罰のスーツで行ってくるとでやっぱりのイメージですね人間が持って
イメージというものは
展示ではないって言う
この一年
ここをと話をしていきたいなと
思っています
そして a 今日その
有名無名のいう明治の時代を斬るという話の裏もテーマがその現実を変化するよと
今日はそうですねまあターンテーマもネクストっていうことで誤解だったら自分でも何
か出来ることがあるといいねって話なんでそこに合わせていくんですけど
現実の変換ですよね
8実は今日も実はちょっと変かなとかだったらいいなと思っているけど
ペットでフリースタイルラップやる馬鹿は俺ぐらいというふうに思っています
阿蘇ことが起こるんですね昨日までなかったものが
の一瞬ねーいろんなことを頃で起こってしまうと
そういう時代になったということですね
でこれ現実の変換動画読んでますけど何が変化したか
それはですねまぁやっぱり時代が次の時代に入ったってことなんですけども
まあ皆さんもご存じだと思いますが ai デザイン切ってますね
人工知能が出てくるよ
でなく恐怖を煽るような合うよというか共感2と思うんですけど
5年後10年後になくなっちゃう仕事はこういうのだよっていうふうに好バランスがさ
れていると
っていいよねえええ
私はここにいるのは
facebook のか sns をフル活用してるわけですね
で前自分の名前が売れてなかったです実際今日も
の持つ名前を知っているもラップ管理を流してくれてる人が多かったという
それでいいと思ってるんですけど
インターネットのレバレッジを効かせるっていう所入っていますレバレッジての後で
また説明しますが他の鉄鋼の力っていう意味ですね
そしてコンテンツとそのネットのレバレッジというのを効かせることで社会の構造が
どんどん変わってきたと
今までやっぱりいい大学に入っていい勝入って大きい四方の中でやっていくという社会
だったものが
1個人でもですね
まあこういう場合たてる奴と
いつもまにかその社会っていうのは変わってしまったと言うんです
まだあんまりリアルにこうピンと来てないかもしれないですけど
本当にその工夫をすることで
司法がなくても十分やっていける世界お金を稼いだり
パンを作ったりこうやって人の前で喋ったりすることが十分可能な社会がもうすでに
やってきたということです
そしてですねその変化する現実ですね変化する現実
じゃあ現実って何なのかっていう話ですね
少し深いところに話をやっていきますので全体の流れてからが違うかなってを感じるか
もしれないですけども
現実というのは
庭園の現在のことです今現在ですね
過去でも未来でもない
ea の現在これが続いていくことが現実と
いうもんです
そして現在というのは一瞬で全ての調子が変わってしまうなんですよ
わかりますかー
どんなに流行っていてもどんなに正しいと思ってもすべての言葉
時代奥になっていくんですそれは新しい技術や新しいコミュニティあ何か新しいものが
生まれたときに上司が変わってしまうからですね
そして今起こっている大きな変化というのはネットのレバレッジが誰でも使えるように
なったという
いうことです
レバレッジ店はまあさっきも言ったようにてこの力です
でこれは具体的にはインターネットの力ですね
何を思ったかというと
ピッチ個人が世界に向けて情報発信できるんだったと
そして誰もが一瞬で世界の情報にアクセスできるんだったと
そのこそとは例えばスマートフォンだったら月額7000円って発生とか
インターネットだったら一番安いのはネットカフェで言ったら1時間300円ですかね
その程度のコストで世界でつながれるになっちゃったんですよ
逆にと世界情報も発信できるなっちゃったんですね
そして a まあそのコンテンツとネットのデバイスと ai っていうのでしょう
一番最初に変換何か変化が起こったかっていう話をしたんですけど
3つめのポイントはコンテンツです
me 情報社会の今店です
これがその個人が生きていくかあるいはいけないかということを決めるポイントになっ
ていると
日々感じていますそのコンテンツというのはとにかくオリジナルなもの
そして
世界あるいは相手ですよね自分が発信したいものではなくて
望んでいる人が必ずいるんですよね世界や
となるいぇあ学校や社会車屋どこにでもいるんですけど
世界が望んものそしてオリジナルのなものこれを私はコンテンツだというふうに定義し
ています
この変化する現実とインターネットのレバレッジ
そしてオリジナルがコンテンツこの3つをうまく使うことで誰もが無名な有名人になる
ことができるそしてその世界の中で生きていくことができます
どうやってんか
これはステップ1はまずやっぱり0から1にしない時ですね
ゼロからイチこの変化が起こる前というのは
基本的にはその価値を生む行動というは
どこか会社から与えられたり学校から与えられたり親から与えられたり自分で自分の
価値を定義する必要がなかった社会なんですよ
なかったできるのはちょっと語弊があるかもしれないですけど
今の際というのはより自分の価値を自分で定義しなきゃいけないと
そして0と一応じゃなきゃいけない01をやるのは結構難しそうだなと私に相方の価値
があるのかってよくみんな
おっしゃる方がいるんですけどこれ簡単なんですね
えっとまずはその自分はオリジナルだっていうことを認めるって事ですね
で先ほどですね
情報社会のコンテンツがまあオリジナルでえっと誰かが望んでいるものだという話をし
たんですが
オリジナルっていうのはどういうことかっていうと実体験を持っているなんていうこと
ですね
実際に思っているか
例えば私はらこー始めたのが6か月前なんですよね
だからっ
6か月前なんですけど実体験があるんで
やっぱりなに待ってない人にも少ししゃべり剤とか
取材の申し込みが来てまたそれで自分もレバレッジがかかって人に知ってもらいたいと
かあるいは初めて会ったと思うと自己紹介でラップを披露しでいきなりなかなかがれ
たりとか
ような良いことが起こるわけですこれが集まりもうすでに0から1になってるって事
ですね
例えば料理を作れるとか掃除ができるとか
あいさつができるとか
犬の散歩が得意だとか何でもいいんですそれにきちっと価値を自分で認めるって言う
ことこれが
step 1ですね
そして
何 vip 他の人とかぶらないようにしていくというのが重要になってきます
つまりそのインターネットっているは検索すればどこにでも嬢も転がっていますから
他の人と一緒だとですね
あんまりこう見てもらえないですね
なんですけどこれをみたいなちょっとメディアはせてしまったんですがなんかの
メディアで最近列の話でまた自分のキャラクターのレイヤードをあげましょうと
いう話ですね
これはたとえば私はマーケティングはショートです
そしてラップも行っています
私がその今メディアの人から注目していただいているのはマーケティングをランプで
あるっていうところですね
あの韻を踏むっていう技があるんですけど
まずの引用符のことで頭をまさに印象に残るんですけどキャッチコピーにそのラップの
スキルを使いましょうというイベントをやっています
そうすると例えばこの100人の中でラップをそれなりに
トレーニング主がわたしだけでしょう
そしてマーケティングもそれなりにお金に換えてきたのも
まあも何か良いかもしれないですけど
なんでのの学校を動かし例えば私一人だったとしましょう
そうすると1/100掛ける1/100で1万分の1の人間られるんですね
例えば英語がビジネスでレベルで話せるっていう人がいてその人が犬の散歩やりますと
どっちもが100人ぐらい
100人分の1の確率だったとしてもその2つを組み合わせることで実は1万分の1と
いうですね他の人にはかなわない
とてもとてもレアはですねキャラクターに行こう
自分を高めていくことができるとこれが step 1です
そして step 2 day
1からセンっというコミュニケーションを図っていくということです
このシガー
3年前に今独立をして
個人に後いろんな活動をしているんですけれども
それが成功した本当にま唯一の理由というのが本当インターネットをフル活用したって
ことですね
特にですね
あのラップ会議だというのは6広告系も全然かけてないですし
勧誘とかもしれないですね
テレビで
ラップのパン君が最近増えているのをご存じですかね
ラップの cm ってるのかまで増えてますねなんか方あの ok の保険会社さんと
か最近だとなんかなんだけどよっぽよ版の cm か何からラップで言ってましたけど
やっぱりちょっと土煌ラップの部分が来てるなんていうことを僕薩長したんですね
で弾っていうことはつまりそのインターネットでコーヒ探す人も増えるだろうと
そこを狙ってコンテンツを考えていたわけです
1観戦のコミュニケーションここで一番重要なことそればやっぱり相手中心に考えると
いうことです
一番最初にちょっと点を挙げていただいたんですけどラップ会議知ってる人にも
僕を知ってるとのが少なかったという
僕はこれでいいと思ってるんですね
僕のことは別に知られなくていい
自分個人はそんなに目立たなくていいそれよりも自分が誰かのために役に立とうと思っ
たことあるいは何か社会に移行
与えないと思った勝ち
本店にそのものが目立てばそれでいいです
なぜならばインターネットで何かが結果ってに検索をしてくれて
誰かが勝手にシェアをしてくれて
自分が頑張って一第一で話さなくてもどんどんレバレッジがかかっててこの力がかかっ
て広がっていくからです
で今日もですねえええ
18分私にはたられますねで会場には100人くらいの人もいます
これ掛け算すると1800分ですよね
18分かける訳
184310時間なんですよ
僕はこの18分
の時間を使うだけで実は30時間分の
[音楽]
この無名のいう明治の時代を生きたがもっといいよって話を完了することができるん
ですね
ありますかそうそのレバレッジを引いている1800と100倍の仕事量を同じ時間で
完了ができるということです
この市川西のコミュニケーションというのは
お金がなくなかったりは資本力がなかったり組織力がない個人が最も意識して活用する
べき日あるいは情報というものはどんどん広がっていきます
そして最後のステップ3現金化するということです
現金館まあその他ねあこれなんか言葉ってデートはちょっと他での中カップの財布行っ
ちゃダメなっていうあるなんてなんですけどど自分の価値を自分で定義基地とするって
ことですね
最初は100円でもいいです
例えば私のイベント
んですって言って
銀河工房
指定する
コンテンツの名前に対してこれ看板ですよねコンテンツ
皆さんか書いていると一緒で
love イベントって
ねえ参加費100円
この参加費100円って言う
いいんですよね金額を
ちょっと設定するここで初めて
その価値が生まれてくるわけですコンテンツとして成立し始めるわけです
f 1からさんこれを
やりきることで
誰でも誰もか
このインターネットの時代は無名の有名人になることができ
私が実際この活動をやり始めて本当にいろんな方と出会って
感じたことを
それは
時代の
そのテンプレートが本当に強くなってきていると
今までのように
正攻法方などって過去をなぞっていては
本当に生き残れないかもしれないし
自由を得ることはできないかもしれない逆に言うとインターネットを上手く活用すれば
誰もが自由に自分の価値観で生きることが可能な社会になったということですね
まずは自分のできることをそこにして十勝を振り出すそこから今日帰ったらですね
ぜひ始めて欲しいと思いますで願わくは現金化
価格をつけてインターネットで拡散を試みてやっていただければ
言うかなと思います
ちょっと時間なりましたので以上とさせていただきますありがとうござました
[拍手]